make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are getting into James tin Ian's Batman
run and we're I mean at the end of the
video we're gonna talk about punch line
a lot of the guys have been asking about
her we don't really have any information
on her right but a lot of guys have been
asking so I figured I would title this
you know punch line the the Joker's new
girlfriend up but she's had some scant
appearances and from what I understand
she's not really gonna be a major player
in in Batman comics until we get to the
Joker war but you guys have been asking
about her you bet asked me to dump some
information on her so at the end of the
video I'll give you guys what we have in
any event here's the thing about James
tin Ian's run right and this is one of
the things that kind of be weary of when
it when it comes to two stories right
James tin Ian's Batman run is amazing so
far but so was Tom Kings and the issue
is that by the time he got to the end of
Tom King's run it really kind of just
seemed to be an exercise in
self-indulgent with a gravely cute story
that really just didn't go anywhere it's
possible tin Ian's run could go in that
direction we don't really know yet but
the cool thing about this is that Tinian
is writing Batman the way he's been
writing Detective Comics which is
awesome because his run on a Detective
Comics is amazing like it's it's
ridiculously good I feel like it's one
of the unsung heroes of like DC right
now Riley is a super good story but what
this does is it initially picks up
seemingly with a kind of coming together
of various villains right for the first
person we really pick up here with is a
character by the name of Cheshire dirt
now Cheshire ire is a long-standing
enemy of the Teen Titans the funny thing
about chesh hire is she's unique in
you're really in comparison to a lot of
the different like mercenaries and
villains who are out there right because
when you look at the people who are here
you have like mr. teeth which will we'll
talk about him here in a little bit
you've got Malcolm Merlyn kind of the
antithesis of Green Arrow and the the
Green Arrow comics you've got you know
you got gunsmith who's atcha a pretty
cool character in and of himself and
then of course you have a fifth person
here we'll find out who they are here in
a second but chesh Shire among all the
various contract killers out there is
unique it because of the fact that
basically her hair her fingernails
things like that are all tainted with
different poisons right so like at any
point in time she could scratch you and
you could die from like the venom of an
ASP snake or in this instance where she
killed the doorman the venom of what was
basically a box jellyfish like these
things are cool right it's one of the
things that makes her really intriguing
and really interesting but it makes her
difficult to capture right because she's
like a tree frog right like it like an
Amazonian tree frog did the entirety
her body is basically a giant poison and
so if you were to touch her you were to
grab her hair or you were to be
scratched by her nails or bit by her or
something like that or even possibly
touch her skin you could die and so it's
interesting like she's really intriguing
in that way but what this also does is
it kind of switches over to Catwoman now
here's one of the cool things here right
with Selina Kyle this is one of the
things that I love about what tinium is
doing that that Tom King did differently
whenever Tom King had like Batman and
Catwoman talking it just didn't sound
natural right it was it was like
watching an Alan Sorkin show right so
like the newsroom or like The West Wing
where people have conversations but no
one really talks like that in real life
and it kind of removed you from the
comic right like nobody talks that way
like when they would communicate and
things like that
tinium does a really really good job of
having discussions between characters
and it really just kind of feels organic
the way that Selina Kyle and that woman
talk it's not the most important thing
out there but it is kind of a cool thing
the other part of this that you really
end up learning here is that Bruce Wayne
is kind of go Early's badass going
headlong into the notion of like
developing gotham city and he's going
into the notion of like developing
Gotham and just making it a better place
as opposed to I'm running around as
Batman and I'm beating up criminals in
the middle of the night like I'm some
kind of schizophrenic and like and
that's my that's my shtick that's my
thing right like he's actually working
to improve Gotham more so than he ever
did before and in fact Kenyon will kind
of address this unlike years past but
the cool thing is that that what he ends
up doing is is really kind of having
this conversation with Lucius Fox right
where Batman is in the midst of
developing this now we're not really a
Batmobile but not really a batwing kind
of a blend between the two to a degree
which is somewhat of an interesting idea
but the big takeaway from this is he
basically says that about five days
prior on the dark web that the the back
computer picked up a message that was
sent out and then deleted three minutes
later and what has basically did was
kind of send out a message to five of
the most capable assassins out there in
the world and basically said meet in
Gotham City on this day and we're gonna
complete a mission and that basically
Deathstroke is the one who's leading
them and this is an interesting thing
here because Batman really sort of
analyzes all the villains who were there
and it's just kind of like okay each one
of these guys are interesting you know
mr. teeth and gunsmith and Cheshire and
so on but the only person I'm really
worried about here is Deathstroke
because for Deathstroke is about the
money but also about the principal if
somebody's gonna hire him for a job it
has to be worth doing right because
Deathstroke has enough money so it's one
of these things where he doesn't really
need
is it worth my while to even take this
job in the first place what she can kind
of command right he's like the premier
assassin in DC Comics so like if you
really want somebody to die
Deathstroke's the guy you get hold of so
it's kind of interesting and so because
of this bat may have essentially planned
for for a lot of these villains to take
them down but also realizes that
Deathstroke's mind operating as fast as
it does and in fact is kind of
established here nine times faster than
the average man means a Batman has to
act and then respond and really an
exceedingly short amount of time
otherwise Deathstroke will mentally get
the upper hand and this is an important
thing because what it shows here is that
while Bruce Wayne doesn't really
consider Deathstroke to be an equal he
does consider Deathstroke to be somebody
worth worrying about
and Deathstroke isn't a lot of ways an
equal to Batman not you know strictly in
terms of fighting but in terms of his
ingenuity how his mind works his ability
to comprehend and understand situations
to get in and out of different scenarios
as fast as possible I mean for God's
sake the guy was facing off against
Superman and just throws like glowing
green rocks at and tricks Superman into
thinking it was kryptonite right so like
small little things like that or what
really make Deathstroke unique and
intriguing here so of course Batman
execute this plan and basically you know
throws out what are called the bat
shadow casters and what these are
designed to do is basically kind of emit
a shadow that more or less follows these
various villains around and then tricks
them into believing they're leading
Batman into a trap where they can
somehow take him out when in reality
he's not there now of course going
toe-to-toe against Deathstroke is a cool
thing to see with Deathstroke being
there him and Batman facing off against
each other
it's largely been established multiple
times over DC Comics that sometimes the
battle can actually go either way that
sometimes destro can win but because of
his super soldier enhancements sometimes
Batman can win because Batman's just the
best fighter in in DC Comics but
regardless you know basically what
Deathstroke says here is like you
fighting me this is the distraction this
is this is part of the big plan right
like this is all going the way it's
supposed to and Batman's response is I
know exactly what's going on like I know
what it is you're trying to do and NASA
we basically pick up with Catwoman who
followed a guy down into this kind of
sub-basement with all this information
where the plans of Bruce Wayne in fixing
Gotham City and and kind of what it is
that he wants to do with the city as a
whole or intend to be replaced with a
new set of designs by a person called
the designer and the cool thing about
this is that when when you know this
happens when this goes down and Catwoman
confronts this guy ultimately he's just
kind of like
you have to stop this guy like I don't
care what you have to do but you have to
stop this guy's plans from coming to
fruition after which this guy
immediately begins to die kind of
breaking down and so on but a
disembodied voice seemingly starts to
kind of come out out of this guy's body
and basically saying like Catwoman I see
you I know you're here you know you have
to understand this plan that that was
concocted some time ago that you were a
part of it's now coming to fruition
right the designer is coming for Gotham
City the Catwoman immediately picks up
on what's going on and so what this does
is it hits back to this idea that
somewhere along the line and part of the
of the history of Gotham City which we
haven't really known about before that
Catwoman seemingly
made a deal or made some kind of a
bargain with this designer guy but we
don't really know how far this goes
right is kind of hitting at this idea
now there's some pretty clandestine
stuff going on but the cool thing about
this is that this rabbit hole goes down
pretty far and we'll find out how far it
goes but what this does is it jumps to
Batman who basically jumps on his
communicator and says Alfred send a
priority signal to the Gotham City
Police Department and this is this is
cool because my initial thought was oh
my god Gotham's back but it's
interesting to see Tinian kind of
picking up on what it is a Tom King did
and continuing that continuity because
Alfred's dead and that's where Lucius
chimes in and says Alfred isn't here
anymore man like Alfred's Alfred's gone
Batman and Batman slipped right he knew
that bit alfred was gone but it was one
of these things where he's so used to
doing it it's crushing for him to have
to have to admit that Alfred's not here
and he actually just kind of you know
seems to cry I mean some of it seems
like rain but I would say Batman kind of
seems to cry in response to this and so
he basically tells Lucius grab that that
ship thing you know we'll grab the
villains and we'll take them off and
that'll basically be the end of that and
so what you basically end up doing is
you end up jumping to Riddler who's
having a conversation with the penguin
of course the penguin killing various
people who are there and this is when
things get cool because what the Riddler
says is I've been watching everything
that's been going on with Gotham City
I've been watching all these things take
place so on and so forth and like the
the designer is coming to town right the
designer is here in Gotham City the
responsive penguin is yeah I know and
I've taken out anybody who knows what it
is that I've been doing right who knows
about my plans or anything like that
literally all the villains are basically
cleaning house whatever whoever this
designer is whoever this this guy is
here whatever or whatever it is he's
capable of and whatever he's about it's
scaring the hell out of the villains
right it's scaring them enough
penguin is killing off his henchmen so
there's no one there to drop any
information and the Riddler's scared out
of his wits
right the Riddler's just like dude this
guy is no joke and so it's kind of crazy
because you know we've seen things with
like Bane taking over Gotham City so on
and so forth the difference between this
this you know the way this is going down
and what Tom Kane did is that in this
story you feel the stakes you're like
okay so like something's getting ready
to pop off in Gotham
something really bad is getting ready to
happen but that's the thing is if the
Riddler's response is like the designer
is coming to collect the designer is
coming for all of us coming for all of
us as the villains and English responses
he can try and so this is when things
get interesting because from there you
pick up with the various villains of
course who have essentially been
apprehended by Batman and what you learn
is you have this place called the black
bloc and the black bloc is basically
this this prison this designed to hold
people that are escaped as escaped
dangers now the reason why this is
awesome and this is an amazing invention
by by James Tinian because I'm pretty
sure he's the one who made it when you
look at the Batman mythos and you look
at like Arkham Asylum Arkham is for the
most part a revolving door right likes
to face or penguin or Joker or any
number of those guys Riddler Mad Hatter
whoever you know the mr. freeze they're
busted by Batman and then it's only a
matter of time before they escape from
Arkham in order to avoid this what
Batman had done working alongside Lucius
Fox and Andrew even the Gotham City
Police Department was create the black
bloc is a place were escaping cruise
rights like Bane and Joker people like
that who present a clear and present
danger to Gotham City itself could be
held and detained but you basically got
ten feet of cement which is lined with
concrete the idea is that like no one
can get out of here right like once
you're in you're in and there's only two
ways in and out of this whole black bloc
the first one is basically a DNA encoded
set of keys that are only used by Gotham
City Police Department and the second
one is an interest that only Batman
knows about and so when Batman gets in
there and starts talking to -
Deathstroke Deathstroke is immediately
like hey man like you know I'm not gonna
tell you who it was it hired me so don't
waste your time the other people don't
know so they can't tell you but here's
the thing one I'm gonna break out of
here right I'm not gonna be in here
forever this is a cool little game
you're playing and I like that you
believe you can hold me it's cute but
understand I'm
Deathstroke right like I will get out of
this place and then to this is a game
that you're playing is it's interesting
to watch you play this game because
you're going to lose and it's gonna be
fun to watch you fail this is a game
that you will not win so wish me luck
when I get out of here
and that's when Batman basically tells
Bullock who's basically operating as a
commissioner presumably because of the
events of the Batman who laughs and the
fact that Commissioner Gordon is
basically there with what the Batman who
laughs as part of his you know evil
group or whatever is evil justice Lee
who cares nobody's reading that anymore
the thing is like when he basically has
the cell of Cheshire Iyer opened up
Batman rubs her face and then realizes
that it's clay that is a body double
right like it's not actually trash
higher herself and so immediately goes
on the defensive with lucious as track
you know find Cheshire I track her down
they successfully do they end up
locating her and and one of the most
crazy things to come out of this in this
this back wing deal ship thing that
Bruce Wayne has he shoots himself out of
the rail gun he literally shoots himself
out of the rail gun in order to track
her down as fast as possible because of
the fact that the building she's
traveling between are too narrow for him
to just like swoop down and and pick her
up with like some kind of a chain and
then do like he did in in Detective
Comics number 27 where he just hangs her
and this is like she's better off this
way but nonetheless you know jumping out
of here or at least when when Cheshire
makes that makes her move to try to take
out Bruce Wayne and then immediately
goes to basically dig her nails into his
ax into his skin that the intention is
that he's gonna end up dying from
whatever poison he's exposed to now of
course this leads to basically Cheshire
are being hit by a truck while Batman
slides underneath it and while it's not
enough to kill her it is enough to
incapacitate her and of course Batman
reveals that he basically had a kind of
membrane in his suit that essentially
absorbed the poison so you know Batman's
patate armor strikes again but then at
that moment suddenly Deathstroke and all
of his guys escape from the facility and
that's what we basically in a finding
out who that what was going on is that
penguin basically made his move right
penguin had jumped in here and penguin
was the one who freed all of these guys
he's the one that got them all out of
there which is kind of a cool thing to
see and so then what you do is you
basically jump to to the Riddler having
a conversation with Catwoman that
Catwoman's basically made her way to a
cemetery after that you know
conversation with with the one guy who
she believed to have been dead ends up
having the conversation with her and
basically saying hey I haven't used this
line for quite some time but you have to
understand we all made a deal with the
designer we
made a deal with him and he's coming to
collect so you mean anybody who was
involved with that we're all either
going to die or we're gonna have to play
ball the indication is that the designer
is going to kill them all right that's
the indication he's going to kill all
the villains of Batman that's why this
is so cool right because the stakes feel
so intense right it's just like dude all
the villains of Batman are going to die
and it sucks especially for Catwoman
because she's a good guy now and it's
one of the things that's really kind of
communicated here when it comes to to
Riddler is he says the whole reason why
we got together with the design there
was to commit quote-unquote a perfect
crime but basically you know house is
being cleaned by all of us me as the
Riddler
I never really had henchmen so I don't
really have to worry about that I'm
basically gonna like I'm getting out of
here like I'm jumping ship the penguin
clean house on his end we have to assume
that if there are any other villains
that are involved they've done the exact
same thing as well
but the belief of Catwoman is that the
Joker somehow involved here and so of
course traveling to the cemetery this
was done for the intention of finding
the Castillo the Joker which she does
he's basically laying down inside this
casket now for those of you guys who
were unsure or who who were kind of
looking at this like what did the Joker
die this this basically appeared to have
happened back in Batman issue number 49
by a Tom King is part of the lead-up to
the wedding that never happened between
Batman and Catwoman and it was kind of
like this Killing Joke moment right
where where Catwoman and Joker got into
a fight and then she slashed his throat
with her claws and they had this great
big huge long you know conversation
basically was Tom King did with
unnecessarily with a lot of situations
but basically at the end of it Joker
seemingly died right he just kind of
seemed to have been dead ever since now
continuity wise I don't know how that
fits in a Doomsday Clock I don't think
DC knows I don't think they really care
enough to figure it all out but the long
and short of it is that at the moment
right now all indications are that the
Joker is dead right so the question
becomes if the Joker is dead then how is
his disembodied voice communicating with
anybody who's out there right like cute
or seemingly communicating with her at
least his Catwoman believed and so the
other part of this is of course Batman
essentially apprehending Cheshire higher
isn't contacted by Lucius Fox who gives
him one of the coolest inventions ever
what he basically says is that inside of
your of your utility belt is a device
called the echo and what the echo does
is it basically allows you to attach it
to any vehicle that's out there which in
turn will hack into the Wayne
Enterprises components within the car
and then basically allow the car's
appearance to change
creates a kind of hologram but it'll
make any car look like a Batmobile and
then it'll allow it to drive as fast as
the Batmobile which is cool because
basically what this means is a Batman's
got a Batmobile in his pocket right like
at any point in time he can just slap
this thing onto a car and then drive off
now Batman as responses like do me too
Jack a car and then turn it into a
Batmobile and then drive and Lucius is
like well it's my car so you're fine but
nonetheless the funny thing is that you
know kind of switching back to Catwoman
in the midst of this whole thing where
she kind of comes to frustration with
the fact that one The Riddler basically
says I'm cutting this line now I'm
leaving they'll be done no more
communication for between you and me
good luck with the designer hopefully
you get out in time but understand that
you're probably gonna have to break this
news to Batman that's something that the
you know is this kind of ultimate
betrayal more or less that you committed
against him without him really knowing
she's also met with the arrival of these
these two kind of henchmen of sorts you
know who basically show up and then
essentially you know almost kind of
knock her out or knock her unconscious
and then start burying her there along
with the Joker you know and so of course
picking up with the penguin
you know the penguin basically there
with Deathstroke and all those guys it's
kind of like look like here's the deal
I'm skipping town where like I'm getting
out of here I don't want to have
anything to do with the designer I know
the designer was the one that hired you
guys I will pay you double your rate if
you guys leave Gotham and then you guys
sign a non-compete clause basically you
won't return to Gotham within a calendar
year and the response to Deathstroke is
you couldn't afford my price right so
you can't even afford double my price
and an intern intends to go and kill the
penguin only for Batman to basically
show up and of course you know he's kind
of told hey man just so you know like
dry it you know attaching the echo to
any car does not give you the kind of
armor than the Batmobile has so just
keep that in mind man it's just a
hologram right so if they shoot you is
you're probably gonna die if you get
shot in like the jaw or something like
that so wear your armor doesn't protect
you but for the most part the various
henchmen who were here or overtaking
like that right I mean they're there for
the most part taken out quick fast and
in a hurry by Batman at which point the
you know district responds stuck like if
you keep fighting I'm gonna kill the
penguin and so it's cool because Malcolm
Merlyn grabs Cheshire the villains make
their escape and Deathstroke slices the
throat of the penguin and it's dude like
when this happened I was like holy cow
dude like dude it's a penguin gonna die
the classic villains of Batman are
basically being killed off you know so
of course this leads to Deathstroke
making the smart move it's a smartest
move for him to
right knowing Batman as he knows him he
knows that Batman will not let the
penguin die right Batman
despite all the glitz and glamor and all
the stuff that he does is a champion of
life right so he's not gonna let the
penguin die and so that stroke noses and
he assumes he says you have one of two
choices either you can come after us and
you can let the penguin die or you can
save penguin but we know you're not
gonna let him die we know how this game
is gonna play out we'll see you when we
see you we're gonna go after our targets
and basically they end up leaving while
Batman goes to save penguin himself and
so with that going down the penguin in
turn spills the beans and basically says
years ago right you never knew about
this nobody ever told you but years ago
myself
Joker Catwoman like Riddler the
underworld essentially United to commit
the perfect crime and the perfect crime
was to take out Bruce Wayne right to
Ally ourselves with the designer and the
designers goal was to take out Bruce
Wayne that these guys here why these the
old Deathstroke and all those guys
they're there to take out false targets
the way this looks like it was supposed
to go down is it Batman was not supposed
to know what was actually going on that
instead you'd have these criminals who
showed up here they would take out false
targets band which hates around try to
figure out what's going on and the
designer instead would basically take
out the plans of Bruce Wayne to destroy
what it is that he wanted to do with
Gotham City itself the other indication
here is that if the designer is looking
to take out Bruce Wayne that would seem
arbitrary right like I mean he's just a
really rich guy as far as the world's
concerned oh the only buddy you know
aside from the Justice League and the
individuals who know that Bruce Wayne is
Batman Bruce Wayne is just a really rich
guy who's trying to make Gotham better
seemingly the indication here is the
designer knows that Bruce Wayne is
Batman like that's that pinus seems to
be what the case is now there you know
it's cool to see that because then you
switch over of course the Catwoman and
Count women basically kind of digs
yourself out you know she's like I'm not
gonna die here like I'm not gonna die
buried alive in a grave with the Joker's
corpse like that's ridiculous
you know she kind of ends up jumping out
and then of course is saved by none
other than Harley Quinn which is kind of
crazy because it's like why in the heck
is Harley Quinn even here we're just
kind of nuts now of course from there
the penguin is basically dropped off and
like a Gotham City Hospital by that man
literally Batman grabbed the penguin
drove to this location out of the
vehicle left him on the steps of the
hospital and was like I got stuff to do
and then left which is kind of screwed
up but Batman ends up going after these
false targets right now this is
important
because what this show is this Batman is
trying to do it all right now the
reality is that man wouldn't let the
false targets die right that was the
whole message of the penguin
you know gunsmith and mr. teeth in in
Cheshire and and Deathstroke you know so
on you know they're gonna go after the
false targets and they're gonna kill
them right so innocent people are
basically going to die if Batman chose
not to go after these guys and that's
kind of the danger of all this right
like the designer really seems to be
orchestrating things in such a way to
where Batman's being pushed to his
limits and in a lot of ways he is
because this comes hot off the heels of
everything that just happened with city
of Bane the death of Alfred and all that
kind of stuff right and so kind of going
after the gunsmith we sort of got a
rundown on this guy this guy's name is
Douglas worth that basically he was a
veteran you know of half a dozen
military contractors as is explained by
James Tinian and then ultimately was
fired from each and every one for using
experimental weapons in the field
without any kind of approval whatsoever
but the reason why he got his name is it
basically he kind of fashioned a you
know a silencer out of different things
that he found from an electronics store
and then killed a guy on a plane that
was full of people and no one knew that
he did it right so he was just that
capable but the issue is that at the end
of the day despite the you know his his
his capabilities with fashioning you
know weapons seemingly out of just
arbitrary components kind of kind of
being like this MacGyver sort of
situation he's no match for Batman right
so he's taken out with a quickness right
I mean that that happens quick fast and
in a hurry following that is mr. teeth
and mr. teeth sort of gained his name
because of the fact that what he was
doing was going through and and killing
people and then surgically removing the
teeth from their mouth and then
surgically putting them inside their
stomachs right now why he was doing that
we don't know probably because he's just
crazy as hell but of course he's taken
out by Batman as well with a quickness
right the other thing behind this is
that they're currently you know he's
currently in the lair of the of the
Riddler and so the indication seems to
be here that these five guys were
basically tasked with tracking down the
classic villains a Batman Catwoman the
Riddler penguin a presumably to face the
Joker you know these major members of
the criminal underworld they're each
going to take out one of them and of
course mr. teeth was here to take out
the Riddler and so with mr. teeth being
removed from the equation this in turn
allows Batman to basically analyze the
the only real footage left there by
Riddler by Edward nygma which was done
of course intentionally for Batman to
follow up on and it's cool to see that
the James Tinian does this right it's
cool to see him look at this and say
okay let's still maintain this role of
the
what Edward nigma was doing is that when
he was confronted by the designer he was
making a series of hand gestures and
these hand gestures were essentially you
know a riddle more or less thrown on a
keyboard of sorts they were more or less
a riddle and Batman understanding and
deciphering this you know picking up
this riddle is basically the question
what walks on four legs in the morning
two legs in midday and three legs in the
evening and the response solution Fox is
will man I have no idea how that makes
sense but of course you know Batman
figuring it out basically says okay this
essentially grants him access to the
computer systems which basically shows
them that the Riddler was running a
track that nobody else was whether the
Batman wasn't or anybody else wasn't
which was on Deathstroke and so that of
course gives him the location of
Deathstroke which Batman you know sends
out his little bat drones in order to
track him down but what this does is
that from here it switches directly over
to Batman and to count woman you know
Catwoman and Harley Quinn showing up and
then got one basically saying like we'd
to talk like we need to have a
conversation I need to tell you about
all of these things you know that it's a
guy called the designer that he's
basically here now Batman for the most
part knows what the penguin told him but
he doesn't really know everything and so
it's at this point when kattleman
apologizes that we get into essentially
the new girlfriend of the Joker a lot of
you guys have been asking about this a
lot of you guys have been asking me
questions what's going on with the
girlfriend of the Joker this is all we
have right this this is it it's
basically just a girl who calls the
Joker and it's just like hey they've
seen the grave but their attentions been
drawn elsewhere and the Joker's response
is okay like I have something else to
attend to well I mean I have other
people to talk to before this goes down
this is it guys like this is all we have
with the girlfriend of the Joker I don't
understand when people are freaking out
over it I mean I get it insofar as it's
the Joker's new girlfriend but aside
from this and like an appearance in Hell
arisen there's nothing else here right
like she's not gonna be a major player
until April or May when it comes to
Joker war all we're gonna get is these
little teaser one-page moments and
that's basically gonna be it right so
this is kind of kind of strange to me
you know in terms of people getting
super hyped up and everybody asking me
about it I just like people who are
asking me to explain the one below all
I'm Marvel Comics we don't know enough
we can't explain it because we don't
know enough and we don't really know
anything about her all we know is that
she's just a character who's there and
that's basically it but the big takeaway
from all this is the Joker is alive fry
the Joker is very much alive we don't
really know how but the Joker is very
much alive maybe he's one of the three
mysterious Joker's and that's
essentially it but without being said
guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explain make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the Rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
I will catch you all later peace
[Music]
[Applause]